hi there steve here
today i'm going to talk about why we
learn languages or at least why i learn
languages a subject comes up regularly
especially with me now trying to learn
three languages and then i'm cramming in
croatian because i'm going there why
why learn one language why learn many
languages i want to discuss my reasons
for learning languages and i would be
interested in hearing your reasons for
learning languages first a few
housekeeping things we are going to set
up a store
in a week or so so people can buy the
t-shirts
we also want to um you know reward
people who help us so but that's going
to be something that will be handled by
mark and his team
uh second housekeeping item with regard
to the many stories thank you for those
who responded and sent me an email
but i have reconsidered because you know
it was so much work to set up the
original many stories making sure
they're done well then you know people
volunteer and then they don't follow
through and then we've got to find more
volunteers then we end up finding you
know we have to complete them so we pay
people to do them and
and we got to control the quality and
they have to be translated into 30 odd
languages and it's just too much work so
that's point number one
uh point number two is that we have 60
mini stories the value of the many
stories is just how many of them there
are and the repetition so if we just get
five more mini stories it really doesn't
do anything for us i also think that you
know the many stories i'm gonna get into
this are very valuable for refreshing
first of all getting into a new language
or refreshing in a language but then we
have to move on to that next level of
content so at link we want to focus our
efforts on making that less next level
of content more readily available uh
whether it be netflix or youtube or
maybe tying up with some publishers who
produce that next level of content so
that's where we're going to emphasis or
focus our time we if there are people
who want to help us one area that we
would really appreciate help is in
you know finishing the translations of
the interface on our website and there
again we would be willing to reward
people with annual membership t-shirts
and things of this nature
and we don't want to
we found too that you can't have five
people doing a task you've got to find
one person who will commit to do it and
then when they complete the task we give
them the year membership rather than
having a bunch of volunteers which we've
had before and with the best of
intentions you know people have other
things happening and
tasks don't get completed so that's to
bring you up to date on that situation
now
why do we learn languages why do i learn
languages there can be many reasons for
example
um i started learning arabic because
obviously this is a very important
language in the world
and it's a very important culture it's a
culture that has contributed
tremendously to the development of world
history
you know there was a period in the 11th
12th 13th century
call it sort of uh
the golden age of arab and islamic
culture when they had southern spain and
the wonders of baghdad and and and so
forth and so on and when they were
the repository
of
a lot of greek learning and collecting
you know indian mathematics and chinese
technology and this then was passed on
by the arabs to the western world which
was a major impetus to the development
that took place in europe over the last
500 years however
whatever it was of interest to me so i
started learning arabic because to me
learning a language is all about getting
to know the people getting to know the
culture expanding my
ability to connect with
people who share the world with me for
this period of time that i'm on the
world so i find that very motivating
but then of course here in vancouver we
don't have many arabic speakers we have
many iranians so i decided hey i can
read the writing now i can learn iranian
and i've always been interested in that
part of the world it's fascinating you
go back to the persian empire
uh and various turkic uh turkish uh you
know uh empires uh you know the uh
seljuk turks and then the ottoman turks
and and of course you got these turkish
communities through central asia so once
i'm into arabic and persian then why not
also turkish and my wife was watching
turkish series on netflix so that was a
motivation so the motivation can be
anything um
when i knew that i was going to go to
romania on business then i
focused on romanian
i was going to go to crete
so i focused on greek i was going to go
to israel but unfortunately hebrew is a
lot more difficult than greek because it
was my first sort of semitic writing
system right to left no vowels and so
forth and i sort of failed in hebrew but
it then sparked my interest in languages
from that part of the world and i move
over moved over to
arabic i may yet go back to hebrew
i am motivated by the fact that there
are lots of speakers of arabic
hebrew is also a historically very
important language but there are only 10
million speakers of hebrew
i may yet go back there but now
for our
50th wedding anniversary my wife and i
are going to visit croatia for 10 days
and then spain for 10 days
so i said well i should take a break
from my
middle eastern arabic persian turkish
language you know
triptych or whatever
uh and i should get
and try to learn some croatian before i
go there because i will enjoy my stay
much more if i can speak some croatian
and understand and understand you know
what people are saying or television and
so forth
maybe communicate
so uh
since monday we're now thursday
since monday i have been doing the mini
stories in serbian because we have the
many stories in serbian
we have a strange situation we were
going to do one language cerebral
croatian or cerbo croat
and so he said well we'll just do it in
the latin alphabet but apparently we now
have a
in the croatian version of the many
stories being developed so we have in
fact two slots croatian and serbian uh
i'm very curious to hear the difference
between serbian and croatian right now
we only have the cro the serbian many
stories and when we do that the uh
serbian slot will be available for both
cyrillic and latin
content of course the creation will be
only in latin the latin alphabet
and so that's the motivation there
what i'm f another reason why i'm
motivated to learn languages
is that it's so much easier than it was
i remember
when i
tried to learn portuguese for the first
time
this was long before we had it that link
and i bought living language and i can
still remember where i was when i was
jogging through the rain listening to my
portuguese and i already spoke italian
spanish and french but i had lots of
trouble assimilating portuguese getting
it in me i went to portugal and nobody i
couldn't say anything people just spoke
to me in english
and it seemed like it took such a long
time
now with this croatian i've been at it
for three days i've gone through the 60
mini stories i've read them all saved
the words that i needed
the vocabulary is i would say
50 60 percent identifiable from other
slavic languages so that's not as close
as spanish to portuguese and yet because
of the many stories you just start right
in you listen you read you understand
some you look it up and you continue
listening and and the language just
penetrates this was not the case
even going back say 12 13 years when i
first went to learn portuguese and even
in the early days of link when it took
three four five seconds to save each
word and now it's just faster and faster
i am doing this video on my new iphone
an iphone x all right i think
and so i'm curious to see if the quality
of the video is better but also
linking on the new iphone is like super
fast so it's just everything is making
it easier to learn languages so
i can learn languages because i want to
be able to understand and communicate
when i'm in croatia
crete
romania
i know that the effort that i put into
say greek and romania i can easily
refresh it by going back into my mini
stories like i have done now to get up
to speed in croatian and i'm not
worrying about case endings or any of
this other stuff the the difficult stuff
about
um you know slavic languages i'm just
focused on i want to understand i want
to communicate at some level uh
you know at some point if i want to
become more accurate in croatian i'll do
a serbian i'll do it but so it's easier
it's fun i can do it because i want to
go there and just communicate and
understand or in the case of my
three middle eastern languages it's
because i want to get an understanding
of that part of the world it's possible
that if we get
say hindi or thai
uh up at uh or indonesian we do have
indonesian by the way so then there's an
opportunity to explore other cultures
and i will dive into them using the many
stories and from there expand into
whatever can be found on the internet so
why study languages because it's
interesting it expands you it expands
your awareness of the world it's
actually good for the brain i think the
more languages you learn the better you
get at learning languages i'm a much
better language learner today than i was
10 15 years ago not to mention 50 years
ago
you can communicate you can understand
and it's fun and the faster it is on my
little new iphone the more fun it is so
there you go
uh
and let me know if you have any
questions about the earlier uh
housekeeping uh things that i mentioned
bye
hi there just a quick follow-up i just
come back from my workout
my um airpods listening to my uh
croatian many stories
i may have you know i was kind of
reconsidering the whole issue of the
mini stories
um of course anyone can load up anything
they want upload anything they want to
link so if you are if you want to create
a story there was a person in siberia
and bernarul who wanted to make a story
others who wanted turkish and and and
portuguese and so forth danish you can
always load them up if you let me know
and i like them i'm going to give them a
rose and that'll move them up so they'll
be more noticeable you do earn a modest
amount of points
with this it's not a significant income
so that's always there and of course any
content in our libraries is available
for anyone to take away free of charge
if they don't sign up as a paying member
if they don't
uh use the functionality they can use
whatever is in the library so it is free
in that sense the other option is to
think about some way that we have a
common website where people just load
these stories
so there may be some ideas along those
lines uh the existing many stores of
course exist in their identical in a
whole bunch of languages and i think
that is helpful i think when i go to
learn a new language the fact that i
know the story helps me because i kind
of understand what's happening
we don't have to repeat that we can have
unique stories for each language so
we're getting the repetition but we
don't necessarily have the stories
translated and and recorded in other
languages so i just want to throw that
out there because i don't want to turn
off the idea if there's people hey there
who want to create these stories the
three-part stories with the repetition
maybe we can find a way to make that
happen so i just want to add that before
i go and have my shower
you